من مدينه البصره الجنوبيه العراق حيث قال
اتحاد كره القدم العراقي ان مباراه نهائيه
خليجي 25 ستقام في موعدها المحدد مسار يوم
وكانت وكاله الانباء العراقيه قالت ان
شخصا واحدا توفي واصيب 60 نتيجه تدافع بين
المشجعين في محيط ملعب الجذع النخله
بالبصره قبل ساعات من المباراه النهائيه
بين منتخب العراق وعمان في نهائي بطوله
خليجي 25 انا اقرا مراسل الجزيره عن بعض
شهود العيان ان عدد المصابين قد يكون اكثر
من هذا الرقم بسبب الاعداد الكبيره
الموجوده للمشجعين في محيط الملعب وداعت
وزاره الداخليه العراقيه للمواطنين من غير
حاملين تذاكر المباراه الى عدم التوجه الى
المدينه الرياضيه في البصره من جهتها داعت
وزاره الرياضه العراقيه الجماهير للسحاب
من محيط الملعب لان اعداد المشجعين تعيق
اقامه المباراه وفق تعبيرها